snoop dogg gives our favorite interview
ever
plus we're with the guys from Hanson
well folks I'm officially to four to
holiday party round two and I'm not well
I will spare you from looking at me for
too long and thankfully I wasn't the
only one turning up last night Snoop
Dogg hit the carpet at the GQ Men of the
Year party looking oh so dapper and just
watch this amazing interview he gave
with our Lauren Zima it's so good I'm
literally playing the whole thing for
you guys enjoy you're looking good
they're yelling puff puff pass that you
over here ain't ready for this they
talking like they want it but I am ready
for this are you already taking it out
I'm just you know getting my mind right
before I go up in his party what's
Christmas like at snoops house a lot of
trees a lot of gifts a lot of joy a lot
of happiness you know and no mistletoes
you know people love your relationship
with Martha Stewart has she have her
teachings influenced Christmas at all do
you do any Martha Stewart dishes at home
I'm looking forward to making some cake
soon you know some Christmas cookies
that she showed me how to do so I'm
gonna see what they look like and how
are you gonna celebrate the new year I
don't know yet figured out as it comes
you know right now I'm just trying to
figure it out I try to see where I'm at
the end where I want to be when it hits
12 o'clock okay what about in 2018 what
does snoop want to do what are you
excited for next year just want to be
alive can we get a next on EP maybe with
that little cigar
okay
this big Snoop Dogg and uh you know
what's next we own TT that was Snoop
Dogg and he was everything we wanted him
to be Wow snoop happy holidays
love you man good job Lauren okay
meanwhile I'm gonna take you guys back
to 1997 when we were all jamming to ol
Bob 20 years later and Hanson is still
going strong and 2017 was a huge year
for the guys they toured dropped a
greatest hits album and a Christmas
album as you can imagine fans still go
nuts for them as our so Keisha Lacy
found out two decades in the business
and you guys still get Fant like crazy
fan reactions like hormonal teenager
level fan reactions you guys I think
have dealt with it so graciously over
the years and and that's gotta be hard
for you being as young as you were we
got into this because of what we're
pursuing and ending the heart of of
doing something for a long time is
really knowing why you're doing it in
the first place and in our case we were
always doing it for ourselves right
doing it for our own Drive and I think
kind of conceded it's more that you know
what you're centering and so it is
extremely flattering to have people
enthusiastic and of course as a young
guy of course like a bunch of girls
screaming is not a bad thing
to be honest though I think it would
have to be really hard on your wives to
put in that position initially when
you've all first started dating right
they struggle with all the screaming
girls well no they're all like we won
and also on another note I mean if you
starting with the idea of a whole are
they fans or our wives fans of what we
do I mean hopefully you're as big a fan
of bigger fan yeah and that's the whole
idea
so it's you know it's that's the premise
of feminine enthusiastic about you know
our occupation is sort of part of the
package absolutely all right watch his
legs move in my body
god Sophie also played a game of truth
or drink with the guys drinking their
own hops beer check that out on our
YouTube channel now
all right guys clearly I'm in the music
mood and it just so happens to be new
music Friday kicking things off with
Camila Cabello new single off her debut
album now if you thought Havana was a
bob way tweet here never be the same
[Music]
mm-hmm yeah I still have my water
because I need to hydrate okay this next
one comes courtesy of Miko's and
marshmallow it's called danger and it's
off the soundtrack of the new Will Smith
movie bright misfire
[Music]
I'm a pig I can prove to you
but the little money no keys but give me
come on dig something put a bag in the
prize can't help listen to that with
that piece so good alright finally this
one I cannot get out of my head
Charli XCX and Tove lo team up for your
new favorite gem which is aptly titled
out of my head so good right are you
guys that's it for me today I'm
exhausted I need to go lie down so like
and share this while I go get lunch